Good morning.
I'm Brian McQuade.
I'm a software
engineer at Google.
I work on making the mobile
web faster and better.
And today I'm going
to talk about building
an instant mobile web apps.
So we'll take the next 30
minutes to cover two topics.
The first will be,
I'll give an overview
of the process my
team actually took
to optimize one of
the apps I work on.
And then in the
second half we'll
take from that some learnings
or some generalizations and best
practices that hopefully
you can take with you
to make your mobile apps faster.
OK, so our goal
specifically, more precisely,
is to render app content
on the phone in a second.
So from the time a user
clicks a link, to the time
they actually start to
see content on your phone
and you're able to interact with
it, should be about a second.
And this one second
target actually
comes from some work
linked here at the bottom
by Jakob Nielsen--
hopefully you can
see that-- that talks about
some different thresholds
of human perception, where,
sort of, behavior changes.
And that one second
boundary is interesting
because that's the point
at which a user will start
to disengage with the
activity they've initiated.
They'll start to think
about doing something else.
And so to keep the user
engaged, to keep them wanting
to use your app, we want to
try to deliver that content as
quickly as possible, ideally
within that roughly one
second boundary.
So a lot of what I'm going
to talk about focuses
on this concept of the critical
rendering path, which you may
have heard Ilya talk about
or others talk about.
At a really high level,
the critical rendering path
is sort of the
sequence of resources
that need to be
loaded and parsed,
usually JavaScript and
style sheet resources,
that prevent content on
the page from actually
rendering from the screen.
So actually it's easiest
to explain, I think,
with an example.
So here along the top
we've got a timeline
that shows how an example page
that I'm using for this example
renders over time, out to 20
seconds on a mobile device.
So we have a performance
problem here.
And the question becomes,
well, why is it so slow?
Why is it taking nine seconds to
render anything to the screen,
and why does it take 20
seconds to finish rendering?
And that's what the critical
rendering path tries to answer.
So if we have an example
network waterfall here,
we can walk through
and try to start
to make sense of what this
critical rendering path is all
about.
So obviously, we start by
loading the HTML resource.
That comes back
with some content.
It might have a style sheet,
and a script resource.
And so at this point
we have-- like I said,
the critical path includes,
usually, script and styles.
These resources
block the browser
from actually painting
content to the screen.
So while a style
sheet is pending,
the browser is going to
wait for that style sheet
to load before it
actually paints
any content to the screen.
So we can't paint anything until
these resources finish loading.
Imagine that we sent out the
request for both of those.
The response comes back to the
JavaScript in nine seconds,
and at that point, we can
begin to paint something
to the screen.
It may not be the content
the user actually wants,
unfortunately.
That's sort of at the end.
But we've sort of
started to paint.
And then from there imagine the
JavaScript resource adds a CSS
resource to the DOM, a
style sheet to the DOM,
and so now that's
on the critical path
for subsequent paints.
Once that loads, we can paint
a little bit more content.
The style sheet maybe had
some stylings for the footer.
Additionally, we've loaded, say,
a second JavaScript resource
from that first
JavaScript resource.
And say that's used
to actually render
the main content on the screen.
And so that now
has to load, parse,
and execute before
you can actually
see any content on the
screen-- or, I'm sorry,
see the final content.
And then finally around
19 or 20 seconds,
all of that finishes, that
whole process of these things
loading in the browser
finishes, and we
could paint these finished
content to the screen
and show that the user.
So the critical
rendering path tries
to focus on the most
significant resources that
cause render-blocking,
and explain
why we see these delays.
But this becomes especially
important on mobile, where
we have these very high
network round-trip times,
and loading extra
JavaScript and CSS resources
ends up having a
significant cost.
So now, we'll focus
more on thinking
about optimizing critical path.
We know, here, that we've got
this really long critical path
of resources.
This is just a toy example.
So the question becomes,
how do we actually
address and optimize that?
I'm going to talk about
the process my team went
through about a year ago to do
just that for one of the apps
I work on, PageSpeed Insights.
So PageSpeed Insights
is a tool you can use
at
developers.google.com/pagespeed.
This is a tool where you could
enter a URL into the box here.
We go off and we render the
page in a headless browser.
We analyze how it loads.
And we come back and give
you a prioritized list
of recommendations to
make the page load faster.
And about a year ago,
we had this problem.
Well, we started
to think about, OK,
how do we make this page
really fast on mobile?
We knew we weren't doing great,
but the first thing we did
is we wanted to see exactly
how poorly we were doing.
And so what we saw
really surprised us.
It was worse than we expected.
Now you can see where
the example comes from.
It took nine seconds to
render anything at all,
but it took about 19 or 20
seconds on a 3G connection
or on an iPhone 4, in
this case, to render
what the user
actually cared about,
which was that initial
text box that they
could use to interact
with the app.
And so, 20 seconds.
Our target is one second.
We've got a really
significant problem here,
and we knew we needed
to really rethink a lot,
or try to figure out what
we had missed, right?
This app was reasonably
fast on desktop,
but on a high latency
mobile connection,
it just took way
too long to load.
So we started to
look at the markup.
We saw we had some
render-blocking resources
in the head.
But this isn't all
that uncommon, right?
You see this in lots of apps.
So there's nothing that
really stood out here
as being particularly costly.
So we went back to our timeline.
Then we looked at a
network waterfall.
You can see we load
about 25 resources here.
And the question came
up, OK, well we're
loading all these resources,
but which of these resources
are actually contributing
to making the page slower?
Which of these are on the
critical rendering path?
And so one of the things that
PageSpeed Insights actually
does today is it can
tell you which resources
are on the critical
rendering path.
And so we can go here.
We can click through.
And we can see we've got these
JavaScript resources, these CSS
resources that are on that
critical rendering path,
that block rendering of
content on the screen,
and then use that to go
back to our waterfall
and start to focus on
which resources actually
block rendering.
So now we have about a
dozen resources to focus on.
And we're able to focus
more precisely on,
what are the render-blocking
effects of these resources?
And then, how do
we address those?
And so we can begin to
sort of match up here.
We've got some content that
loads before the nine second
first paint.
We can start to notice
which of those resources
are blocking that point.
I'll get into that
in just a minute.
But this was sort of the
starting point for us,
was looking at this
and figuring out,
how do we optimize the critical
rendering path for this page?
At a high level we felt like
we had two problems here.
One was that we had a bunch
of render-blocking JavaScript
and CSS loaded in a way that
blocked any content at all
from rendering the page--
rendering on the page.
So this block of
JavaScript and CSS
here, which declared in
the head of the HTML, all
had to be downloaded,
parsed, and executed in order
for anything at all
to render on screen.
And as we know, mobile networks
have really high latency,
so downloading
additional resources has
a pretty significant,
pretty high cost,
all the while your users are
looking at a blank screen,
waiting and wondering
if your app is working,
thinking about transitioning
away to do something else.
So for us-- and I'll show
it in a little more detail
in a minute-- what we
concluded we needed to do
was basically eliminate
all of these resources
from being render-blocking.
And that amounted to doing
two things, which we'll
dive into-- loading our
render-blocking JavaScript
asynchronously, and
then really thinking
about what is the
minimal amount of CSS
we actually need
to render this out,
and loading that in a
blocking way, but making sure
we weren't loading
any more than we
needed in a render-blocking way.
And so recall, this
is the screenshot
that was associated with
that point in the page load.
The thing to note here is
that we haven't actually
rendered the content
the user really cared,
that text box to interact
with the app yet.
So the second issue
was, we were actually
rendering that sort
of critical content,
the text box, that the user
could use to actually analyze
a page, using a
JavaScript resource.
We made it to download a
large chunk of JavaScript,
download, parse, and execute
that JavaScript before we
actually rendered
that, using JavaScript
to construct the DOM.
So this added another
roughly 10 seconds of latency
here before we could
get to this point.
So all in all, we had at a
high level these two problems.
And so we sat down and we
tried to address these things.
The thing we did for this was
we realized most of the content,
we're rendering it
with JavaScript,
and that's fine and great,
but it just wasn't performant.
And so what we did is we
inlined that initial view.
Or I should say, we put the
initial view's HTML markup
directly in HTML, no longer
depending on JavaScript
to actually render that, which
allowed us to present that
to the user that much
faster without having
to wait for that render-blocking
JavaScript to load.
So I just wanted to show
a quick before and after.
Here's that HTML markup
for the original page that
took 19 seconds, at
least part of it.
We've got our render-blocking
JavaScript in the head.
We've got some markup
for the content,
but we don't have, you'll
notice, the input box.
That was rendered with
JavaScript, so some of that
comes later.
The after case-- here, we've
got a slightly different markup.
First, we've got an inline style
block that contains the CSS.
We need to style the
content in the initial view.
So we don't have
to go to network
to download additional
style sheets, which
will incur additional mobile
network round trips, which
are significantly slower,
or significantly slow
down the page load.
And then as I
mentioned, now we've
made sure that all
the markup we need
to render the above the fold
content is directly in HTML.
We're not using JavaScript to
render any of this content.
And then finally,
because we're including
all the markup we need to
render the initial view directly
in HTML, we can load our
JavaScript asynchronously
because we don't
need it to render,
so we don't want it
to block rendering
of the initial presentation.
So that high level was the
process we went through.
And so the question
is, how did we do?
Did we actually
speed the page up?
So here's the waterfall
for the original page.
We've got about 25
resources in total.
And then here's the waterfall
for this rewrite that
was focused on delivering
a really fast experience
on mobile.
And you can see we've got
about 20 resources now.
So we had 25 before, 20 now.
It's not really
significantly different
if you look at the
total waterfall
size, total number of requests.
But I think what's
really important
here is looking not at the
total number of requests,
but the relative size of
the two critical paths
between the critical rendering
paths, between the two pages.
So in the old example, we had
a bunch of resources here.
We've got everything
we need to render
the initial view in
the HTML payload.
So the critical path, the
critical rendering path,
is this one HTML resource.
And we can render
much more quickly
than in the original case
where we had a dozen resources.
So we often talk
about, well, reducing
requests is a goal
with performance
and with optimization.
But I think what's
more important is
to think about reducing
the number of requests
on the critical rendering path.
That's really where you
will see your big returns.
So let's look.
Let's do sort of a side
by side, before and after.
So the optimized case,
we start to render in
about a second a half,
and we're completely
done at three seconds.
All the images,
everything, have come back.
And recall the original case.
We're still waiting.
We can't actually really
interact with the app, even
at this point, because we
don't have the text box.
So we were able to reduce
the render time down
from about 20 seconds down
to one or one half seconds.
So we more or less
accomplished our goal.
So that's the process
we went through,
and now I'm going to
spend little time talking
about the process of
optimizing your app's content.
So what did we learn?
What are the general
best practices there?
How can you deliver this instant
experience for your users
on mobile?
So the first thing we
learned-- the first thing
we identified as an
important best practice--
is to load script
asynchronously.
So don't load scripts in a way
that blocks rendering, because
on mobile networks, with the
high latency, high round trip
times, each additional
resource you
load in the critical
rendering path
pushes out the time the user
has to wait to start interacting
with your app pretty
significantly.
So here we've got your
sort of standard page,
group source equals all
that JS in the head.
And we've got the
content right beneath it.
The browser receives that
at the same time, probably,
as the script.
But it can't show it to the user
until the script has finished
downloading, parsing,
and executing
on the mobile device,
which introduces
really significant additional
render latencies for the user.
And so what do we do?
In the best case, you
can take advantage
of the HMTL5 async tag, which
tells the browser, yes, I
need this script, I need
to load this script,
but you don't need to execute
it inline at the point
where it appears
in the document.
Execute it sometime later
when it finishes downloading,
and then go ahead
and just proceed
parsing the rest
of the document,
and render that content to the
user as quickly as you can.
So this gets scripts out of
the critical rendering path,
which is a really
important thing to do.
So I'll say there are
some subtleties here.
It's often not quite
as easy as just
dropping the async tag in there.
If you use document.write
in your JavaScript,
this is a really
dangerous thing to do.
And there are other
subtleties that I'd
be happy to talk
about at the session.
And I guess it'll be 45 minutes.
So second, render the initial
view server-side as HTML.
You'll recall we had
about six seconds
of render-blocking
JavaScript and CSS,
but then we had 10 seconds
to load that final JavaScript
resource, download,
parse, and execute it
before the app
finished rendering.
And the problem was we were
loading this big JavaScript
bundle, whose job it was to
actually construct the DOM.
So we had to go to
network in order
to create the DOM that
the user would see.
And this is just, unfortunately,
an inherently slow process
on mobile.
Rendering client-side--
let's talk about-- so
what do we mean by
server-side rendering
versus client-side rendering?
So client-side rendering,
you're using JavaScript
to actually render the
content in the document.
So here we load up that JS.
The DOM itself doesn't
really contain any markup.
It doesn't contain mark up
that you see on the screen.
It's just to figure
out a placeholder div,
and then when app.js
finishes loading,
we might get something like
this that actually constructs
the DOM once that
resource finishes loading.
By contrast, server-side
rendering-- everything
that we need to display
in the initial view
is present right
in the HTML markup,
and so no additional
resources are needed.
As soon as that
HTML comes back, we
can render that to the
screen and the user
sees that as
quickly as possible.
So this is just, on
mobile especially,
this is just a much
more performant approach
for the initial view.
So certainly, once the
app has finished loading,
and the user is
interacting with your app--
they're changing the way
the content is presented,
maybe they're navigating
through a menu-- certainly
at that point it makes
sense to use JavaScript
to construct your document.
But for that initial
view, you should
do as much server-side rendering
to HTML as you possibly can.
So we found this to be true.
But we weren't the only ones.
Twitter also came to
the same conclusion.
So they wrote a blog
post about a year ago
where they talked about this.
In 2010, they'd
released new Twitter,
where all the rendering
happened on the client.
And they talked about
how that allowed
them to do some
interesting new things,
but it came at the consequence
of significant regression
in actual client-side
render time.
So in 2012, they
wrote this blog post
where they talk about taking
back control of front end
performance by moving
rendering back to the server.
And what they found is that
page load times dropped really
significantly.
So wasn't like
10% or 15%, it was
1/5 of what they
were previously.
So this was a really
big thing for them.
And in order to deliver that
instant experience on mobile,
it's pretty much a
requirement that you
render that initial
view server-side.
So Twitter wasn't
the only organization
to come to this conclusion.
Airbnb had a very similar
conclusion in a blog post
earlier this year.
And they said under
their old design,
the external
JavaScript files had
to download,
evaluate, and execute.
Only then would
the app discover,
oh, the user's intent was
to do x, who would call up
the API, which was an
additional network request,
that became part of that
critical rendering path.
Here we are in a
mobile connection,
which has really high latency.
Which led to, for them, a
time to content-- the time
until the user could get the
content that they wanted--
of upwards of 10
seconds, in bad cases.
So then they switched to
server-side rendering--
which, by the way, they open
sourced the infrastructure they
used for this, so it's worth
a look at this blog post.
When they moved to serving the
initial view as HTML generated
on the server, it felt
five times faster.
So similar conclusion, right?
Twitter-- 1/5.
Here, Airbnb--
five times faster.
So in my opinion, if you
want to deliver a truly
instant experience--
and there's a trade off.
So if you want to deliver
that experience on mobile,
you really need
to be server-side
rendering that initial view.
Loading JavaScript to create
the initial presentation
is just going to be
too slow on mobile
for it to be an
instant experience.
And we saw Twitter and Airbnb
both had really dramatic speed
reductions as a result of
adopting this technique.
So I would say, when choosing
a JavaScript framework,
you want to look for a
framework ideally that
supports server-side rendering.
Airbnb talked about the
one they open source.
Not all the JavaScript
frameworks out
there today do support this,
but if you're using one today
that you do like that doesn't
support server-side rendering,
you should push on
the development team
or pitch in and
help out to make it
easy to do that as part
of using that framework.
So you can take advantage
of this automatically.
So the third area I
want to talk about
is minimizing
render-blocking CSS.
And I think this is the topic
we get the most questions on.
So I'm going to go through a
couple common questions here.
The first of which, people
say, well what do you mean CSS
is blocking?
Why is this part of this
blocking critical render path?
JavaScript blocks, yes, but
what do you mean CSS blocks?
And it's correct that JavaScript
blocks DOM tree construction.
JavaScript blocks the parser.
But style sheets block
render tree construction.
So ultimately, in order
to lay out in paint,
we need the style sheet
to have finished loading.
And what your users
care about is content
painted to the screen.
So for them, JavaScript
is-- I'm sorry,
style sheets are
render-blocking.
So it's important to
keep this in mind.
If you load a large style
sheet in the head, that's
going to delay the time it takes
to paint content to the screen.
So CSS is render-blocking.
So what's critical CSS?
What is this?
We talk about this
concept of critical CSS.
You may have heard,
it sort of goes along
with the critical
rendering path.
And how do I identify
my critical CSS?
So critical CSS you can
think of as the minimal CSS
you need to actually
position and style content
in the initial view of your app.
So everything you
need to present
that flash of unstyled style
content for the content
that you display
initially to the user.
And the idea here
is that because we
know CSS is
render-blocking, we want
to minimize the amount of CSS
that we serve up to the user,
in order to minimize the
size of the critical path
and get the content to display
as quickly as possible.
So identifying critical
CSS-- we'll talk about this.
People often ask the question,
well I have all this CSS.
I need all of it.
What do you mean critical?
How do I know what's
critical and what's not?
So again, critical CSS is that
needed to position and style
content in the initial view.
So imagine we have
this alert CSS rule,
and then we've got this markup
served up in the initial HTML.
So it's going to be
visible in the initial view
that references that rule.
We expect it to look like
this on the page initially.
We expect it to have
their proper stylings.
A good way to ask yourself,
is this critical CSS or not,
is to ask well, if I took
this rule out of the payload,
would my initial view with the
content I serve to the user
initially look correctly?
And in this case obviously,
if we took that rule out,
it would get the
default stylings
and look totally wrong.
So clearly, we need this
CSS to style content
in the initial view, and
thus it is critical CSS.
And we want to
serve it up early,
and in a render-blocking way.
So imagine we changed
our HTML markup there.
So you can see before it
was .
Now we decide, OK,
we don't really
want to mark hello
world as an alert.
It's just a normal
snippet of text.
We want it to be styled as such.
So imagine, though, that we
do use the alert class later
in the app.
Like imagine your user is
interacting with the app.
They try to upload a video.
It fails.
You want to show an
alert at that time.
So we do need it, but
we don't need this rule
as part of the initial view.
At that point, it's not
part of the initial view,
and so it's no longer
critical and you
may want to think about loading
that later in the app life
cycle, in a way that doesn't
block the initial view.
So one more bit.
I think this is
actually, probably--
this is somewhat subtle, but
probably the most important
thing we talk
about critical CSS.
The critical CSS is that the CSS
is needed to position and style
the content in the initial view.
So oftentimes, we inline
data URIs into our CSS,
the goal being OK, let's
reduce the number of requests
that my page makes.
I can serve up the
image separately,
or I can inline
right into my CSS.
And interestingly, what we are
doing when we inline these data
URIs for images,
is we're basically
promoting the image from
being non-render-blocking,
not part of the critical
render path, because images
by default-- they obviously
need to download the image
to render the image itself--
but images don't block rendering
of other content on the screen.
When we inline it
as a data URI here,
we basically promoted it
to being render-blocking,
to being part of the
critical rendering path,
and we're making that critical
rendering path that much
longer.
And so data URIs too, they
tend to be quite big, right?
So here's our markup.
So if you look at
your CSS, and you're
using this technique
lots of sites do,
you'll notice
probably the majority
of bites in your CSS
files may actually
be from these inline data URIs.
And what you're doing is, you're
increasing that critical path
length pretty significantly,
and actually causing users
to have to wait to
see any content at all
on the screen as a result.
So you'll actually render the
other content on the screen
more quickly if you just
switch back to that CSS sprite
with the external
file reference,
or, if you're using something
like [INAUDIBLE] where spriting
doesn't really bring
you any benefit,
just keeping each
image asset separate,
reducing the size
of the CSS, reducing
the size of your
critical rendering path,
and making the page load
that much more quickly.
This is pretty easy to test out.
Create a simple page.
Inline a bunch of data
URIs and a style sheet.
Create a second
version that page.
Use the technique
here where you've
got a separate image asset.
Make sure there's some
non-image content on the page,
so put some text in
there, whatever it may be.
And then compare the
two in web page test.
Do a video comparison
on a 3G network.
And you'll see that when
you inline data URIs
into your style
sheet, you're blocking
rendering of all the
content on the page.
You're blocking the
text, whatever it may be.
So on mobile, again where
downloading additional content
in the critical rendering
path is expensive,
I encourage people to
not take that approach--
except for maybe
very small data URIs.
I would say that large data URIs
inlined in render-blocking CSS
are actually harmful
for render performance,
and I would avoid
using that approach.
So then a couple more questions.
OK, so I've identified
my critical CSS.
I've removed my data URIS.
I made it nice and small.
How should I load
that critical CSS?
So there's two ways
to go about this.
In PageSpeed
Insights we actually
in line the critical CSS
as a style block in line,
keeping that critical rendering
path as short as we can.
We don't want to
go back to network
to download an external
style sheet, in our case,
because that incurs additional
network round trips, which
can add anywhere from 500
millis to maybe a second,
depending on how
it's loaded, of time
the user is staring
at a blank screen.
So for us, we felt like the
best approach was to inline.
The CSS needed to style
the initial view directly
in our HTML payload.
But I wouldn't say that's
necessarily a requirement.
I think it's still
perfectly reasonable
to load that critical
CSS resource, as long
as the critical resource
is small, in the head,
as an external resource.
The page will be
slower for people
who don't have the
resource in cache,
because now they
have to go to network
to download that
additional resource.
But you've got some
other benefits.
You're reducing bytes sent
on the wire for repeat views,
because once it's in
cache the user doesn't
have to download it again.
You may introduce a faster
full cache experience
for repeat view.
It really depends.
It's not guaranteed
by any means.
It's sort of a little
counter intuitive.
You would think, well the
HTML payload is smaller,
so the page should load faster.
But it actually depends, it's
not necessarily the case.
But in any case, either of
these approaches is reasonable.
And it really just depends.
You're making a trade off.
Do I want the
fastest performance?
In which case, you
want to inline.
Or do I want a
little bit, perhaps,
more maintainable approach?
In which case you
could keep it external,
and pay a little bit of a
performance penalty for that.
So things get kind of fuzzier
the further along we go here.
So the last bit, once we've
loaded our critical CSS-- now
we've got this other CSS
needed to style other parts
of our app-- how do we
load that in a way that
doesn't block
rendering of the page?
Unfortunately, today there's not
a great simple, straightforward
technique.
Like we have with
script, we have async.
It's a really easy, first
class feature of the platform.
The same does not
exist for style sheet.
Any style sheet found in
the document by the parser
will cause the rendering
engine to say, OK,
I'm going to wait and
not paint anything
until I finished fully
downloading this style sheet.
So you can't just throw link
rel stylesheet href equals
noncritical CSS in the
footer of your HTML.
The parser will find that.
And as soon as it does,
if it hasn't painted
the content above yet,
it will say, whoa,
I'm not going to paint anything,
even the markup above that,
until that finishes downloading.
So you have to be careful here.
So what we want is this
lazy load attribute.
And that's coming soon.
Some Chrome engineers,
IE engineers
are working together on a spec.
And what that says basically--
it's similar to async--
and it basically says,
I need this resource.
It shouldn't block rendering.
It shouldn't block onload.
Load it, and when it's
available, I'll make use of it.
In the meantime, we
don't have that today.
It's coming.
It's being speced.
There are a couple ways
you can work around this.
It's listed here.
requestAnimationFrame,
so you wait for the first paint.
You could load the
resource and hidden iframe.
You could actually
load it as JavaScript.
I've seen people do this.
JavaScript has async, so you
could load a CSS resource
to JavaScript.
As I say each of these, part
of me is feeling not great.
This is really not
the kind of APIs
we want for this kind of thing.
But fortunately, the lazy
load attribute is coming,
and that will be the right thing
to use once that's shipped.
So some high level
recommendations
for render-blocking CSS.
How are we doing on time?
A couple minutes.
Avoid inlining data URIs.
Keep them external.
Keep the CSS as
small as possible.
Critical CSS, what that
is, keeping that in mind,
and making sure you're focusing
on only delivering that.
But all this said--
and if you're
hearing me talk about
this critical CSS
and oh, I have to load
some early and some late,
and that sounds like
a lot of overhead--
the good news is if your
total CSS is reasonably small,
like if it's under
say 15k compressed,
which might mean
45km compressed,
it's probably small
enough that you can just
treat it all as critical.
Just don't worry about
partitioning out.
It's only when it
becomes really big
that you don't want
to load all of it
in a way that blocks rendering
anything at all to the screen.
So the common case, I hope, is
that your CSS is already small,
and you just load that
up front and don't
worry about this concept
of noncritical CSS.
If you do have a
lot of CSS, you want
to load that in a
render-blocking manner--
we talked about the two
techniques for that--
and then load the remaining
CSS in that non-blocking manner
using, for the time being, one
of those requestAnimationFrame
or whatever it may be
techniques, longer term using
that lazy load attribute.
So just to summarize really high
level, the things that we found
were really important.
Eliminate render-block
in JavaScript.
Load JavaScript asynchronously.
Get it out of the
critical rendering path.
So design your apps
with that in mind.
Don't depend JavaScript
having to load synchronously
in order to render your page.
And along those lines,
render the initial view
to HTML on the server.
So don't use JavaScript
client-side to render
the initial view.
It's an inherently slow process.
We saw Twitter had performance
problems with this, Airbnb,
my team had the same issues.
And then finally,
serve up as little CSS
as you need to render
the initial view.
Be mindful of just how
much you're serving.
And largely, you
can accomplish that
by just not inlining large
data URIs in your CSS.
I think if we stop
doing that, I think
our CSS size, for the most
part, will become manageable,
and will be reasonable to
load in a render-blocking way.
So that's everything.